m
les trous noirs sont les objets les plus
extrêmes de l'astrophysique ces objets
incroyablement dense courbe
l'espace-temps si violemment que même la
lumière ne peut pas leur échapper les
trous noirs défi l'intuition et capture
l'imaginaire à tel point que des
millions de personnes sont enfermés
volontairement dans des salles noires
pour mieux les contempler pour moi le
fait que même des noms physicien aime
penser et parler de ces objets est un
succès fantastique de la vulgarisation
scientifique que je suis le premier à
célébrer les trous noirs font partie de
la culture populaire et ça c'est super
trop cool mais du coup il est aussi bon
que l'impression qu'ils sont dit à ce
sujet donc aujourd'hui on va essayer de
clarifier certaines idées reçues qui
sont pas tout à fait juste
et on va faire tout ceci dans le cadre
uniquement de relativité générale c'est
à dire qu'on va oublier toutes les
considérations thermodynamique mécanique
quantique ou théorie des cordes qui sont
beaucoup trop compliqué donc aujourd'hui
on va s'intéresser juste au trou noir de
leur relativité générale et vous allez
voir que c'est déjà assez incroyable
idée fausse numéro un
les trous noirs sont des objets
astrophysiques qui aspire to tell des
aspirateurs cosmique de l'espace temps
pas vraiment en fait si on remplace
notre soleil par un trou noir et ben
orbites des planètes va être
complètement inchangé vraiment vraiment
rien ne va changer
bon il va faire un petit peu plus
frisquet sur terre bien sûr le score
plus large et du soleil mais la terre ne
va absolument pas se rapprocher du trou
noir pas plus qu'elle ne se rapprocher
du soleil ceci dit il ya un petit peu de
vrai dans l'hymne et sur lequel un trou
noir aspire plus qu'un soleil dans le
sens suivant en fait juste à l'extérieur
du trou noir
il n'y a pas de trajectoire circulaire
stable et les objets sont
attirer un peu plus par le trou noir
qu'ils ne le seraient dans le cadre de
la mécanique newtonienne en fait cette
région là ils existent vraiment que dans
le cadre de la relativité générale
signale que des objets ultra denses
comme les trous noirs ou les étoiles à
neutrons qui possèdent cette région où
la gravité vraiment étrange et en cela
on peut dire que un trou noir aspire
plus des trucs qui sont vraiment très
près de lui que ne le ferait une étoile
classique dans le cas des trous noirs en
rotation on trouve des trajectoires
encore plus étrange et là je vous invite
à aller voir ce super épisode de
patience ou ce billet de blog des
docteurs govou lui pour en savoir plus
idée fausse numéro 2 ne fait pas bon
être proche d'un trou noir car la
gravité extrême qui règne de croire et
en un instant
alors il ya quand même un petit peu
devrait si on est prêt de certains trous
noirs en tout cas la gravité peut
vraiment être extrêmes les attention à
ce que l'on entend par gravité je ne
parle ici pas de la gravité en tant
qu'expression d'aller référentiel je ne
parle donc pas de la gravité dont parle
le principe d'équivalence non c'est pas
de cette gravité la dont je parle si
vous tombez dans un trou noir vous
suivez une ligne droite à travers
l'espace temps une ligne droite à
travers l'espace temps c'est une
trajectoire sans accélération donc si
vous tombez dans un trou noir en chute
libre vous ne subissez aucune
accélération vous ne mourrez pas à cause
de l'accélération des référentiels donc
ce n'est absolument pas une force de
pesanteur qui va vous tuer lorsque vous
tombez dans un trou noir
encore une fois en chute libre il n'y a
pas de force de pesanteur en chute libre
vous êtes en apesanteur
si vous risquez de mourir c'est à cause
de la courbure de l'espace-temps qui est
vraiment extrême alors comment est ce
qu'elle se manifeste cette courbure de
60 ans et j'en ai déjà parlé dans les
commentaires de l'épisode 17 de façon
newtonienne c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet de marée et j'en ai parlé de
manière anonyme dans l'épisode hardcore
et dans les commentaires de l'épisode 21
lucioles un trou noir qui se trouve ici
et si on se tient comme ceci alors la
courbure de l'espace-temps va étirer
l'espace dans cette direction il va nous
écarter de la direction de la hauteur et
va aussi nous contractée dans la
direction ortho radial donc en
particulier si vous tombez les pieds en
avant
la courbure de l'espace-temps va vous
étiez dans le sens de la hauteur et va
vous contera
tu es dans le sens de la largeur c'est
ce qu'on appelle la spa gatti fication
puisque vous allez devenir un spaghetti
alors cette spaghetti fication c'est pas
du tout un truc qui est spécifique au
trou noir
en fait en ce moment sur terre je suis
en train d'être spaghetti fier par la
terre sauf que l'effet de cette
spaghetti fication est incroyablement
faible si faible qu en gros je peux vous
dire que je la ressens pas du tout et
quand vous on peut complètement ignorés
dans notre quotidien
les forces électromagnétiques prennent
largement le pas sur ses effets de la
courbure de l'espace temps
connaît-il près d'un trou noir alors
dans l'épisode hardcore on avait calculé
justement cet effet de lag est efficace
si on dit qu'on est juste la surface du
trou noir et que l'on fait bon en gros
en ordre de grandeur un mètre de haut ne
tient alors une accélaration relative de
notre tête par rapport à notre pied en
s'éloignant qui va être de un mètre fois
c'est carey / le rayon de schwarz il au
carré ou le règne de schwarz il une
sorte de mesure de la taille du trou
noir
plus précisément le rien de charge il va
être proportionnelle à la masse et se
calcule de façon exacte à travers
l'équation suivante particulier si on
remplace ici la masse par la masse du
soleil on obtient le rien de chancy d'un
trou noir qui auraient la même masquer
le soleil donc si on place le soleil par
un tournoi qui ferait en sorte que les
orbites des planètes seraient les mêmes
et bien ce trou noir aurait un rayon de
charline 2 3 km à ce moment là l'effet
de marée à la surface du trou noir
ferait que notre tête s'éloigne de notre
pied avec une accélération relative de
banques ou faire ce calcul on obtient 10
milliards de mètre par seconde carré en
gros au bout d'une seconde de votre tête
irl à la vitesse de la lumière par
rapport à votre pied ou en s'éloignant
donc ouais vous ferez bien spaghetti
fier mais considérons le trou noir
sagittarius à l étoile au centre de
notre galaxie
ce trou noir un rayon de foire field de
26 mille années lumière soit à peu près
10 puissance dit m l'effet de marée
c'est à dire l'accélération relatif de
votre tête par rapport à un autre pied
causés par la courbure de l'espace temps
et d' environ un millième de mètres par
seconde car et s'est dit mille fois
moins que l'accélération qui rapproche
la pomme du sol autant dire que l'effet
de marée aux abords des trous noirs
supermassifs et ultra négligeable
idée fausse numéro 3 les trous noirs
sont des régions si extrêmes de l'espace
que rien ne peut leur échapper les trous
noirs ne sont en fait pas des régions de
l'espace mais des régions de white white
l'espace temps et en fait les trous
noirs sont surtout des régions de
l'espace temps qui se trouve infiniment
loin dans le futur et c'est pour ça que
rien ne peut sortir d'un trou noir
sortir du trou noir correspond à
remonter le temps pour comprendre ceci
nous suffit de comprendre le fait que le
temps près du trou noir est
incroyablement ralenti quand - a déjà
parlé dans l'épisode 23 une heure tout
près du trou noir peut correspondre à
des années loin du trou noir et plus on
est près du trou noir plus cet effet de
dilatation gravitationnelle est énorme
tel point qu'au niveau de la surface du
trou noir de ce qu'on appelle l'horizon
des événements la dilatation du temps
est infinie pour ceux qui connaissent un
petit peu le far miss de la relativité
ce que je suis en train de dire ici
c'est que la valeur de des taux sur
d'été pour un observateur qui restent à
la surface du trou noir est égal à zéro
c'est à dire que peu importe la quantité
de temps qui se passe pour un
observateur qui est loin du trou noir
le temps qui passe pour quelqu'un qui
est juste la surface du trou noir est
égal à zéro
encore une fois vous pouvez en savoir
plus en regardant l'épisode hardcore
pour imager tous à imaginer un ballon de
foot qui tourne sur lui-même dans un
trou noir
alors on verrait ce ballon de foot
tournée de moins en moins vite jusqu'à
se figer complètement au moment où il
atteint la surface du trou noir
l'horizon des événements est en fait
plus généralement ça c'est vraiment
incroyable quand on est à l'extérieur du
trou noir et qu'on voit des trucs tombé
sur le tournoi
on ne voit rien rentré dans le trou noir
tout les objets qui tombent dans le
droit en fait se fie au niveau de
l'horizon des événements la surface du
trou noir
enfin ça c'est ce que l'on voit nous qui
sommes à l'extérieur du trou noir
mais si un gamin jouer avec le ballon et
suivait le ballon et traverser l'horizon
des
evènement avec le ballon le gamin lui
vous ne verrez pas le ballon se figer à
la surface du tournoi remise en
traversant l'horizon des événements du
trou noir
il verrait le ballon traverse est lui
aussi l'horizon des événements du trou
noir comme si de rien n'était et on
pourrait croire qu'il ya une
contradiction aussi on pourrait croire
qu'il faudra choisir entre le fait que
le ballon ne traverse jamais l'horizon
des événements et le fait que le ballon
traverse l'horizon des événements pour
résoudre un peu ce paradoxe apparent il
faut bien se rendre compte que lorsque
le gamin traverse l'horizon des
événements il fait un espèce de bons
infini dans le futur que nous à
l'extérieur du trou noir on ne peut pas
faire ce qui se passe dans le trou noir
correspond à vraiment un futur qui est
infiniment loin dans le futur si loin
que en restant à l'extérieur du tournoi
on ne peut pas accéder à ce futur qui
est à l'intérieur du tronc va le gamin
en traversant l'horizon des événements
du trou noir a atteint un temps qui est
en dehors de notre espace pas idée
fausse numéro 4 les trous noirs sont
noirs car même la lumière ne peut pas
leur échapper
ça c'est une idée qui nous vient du
xviiie siècle
et oui et revoir ça fait longtemps que
les gens et les ont imaginés en
particulier un mec comme la place avait
écrit des bouquins sur les trous noirs
pour définir les trous noirs et était
partie du concept de vitesse de
libération
c'est le concept qui a décidé d'étudier
david dans sa vidéo sur les trous noirs
ne garder en tête que ce que dit david
ne correspond pas à la créativité
général puisque la place ne connaissait
pas la relativité générale si vous
voulez mieux comprendre les trous noirs
avec david
je ne sais pas sa vidéo en tant que tel
mais plutôt ses billets de blog où il
était allé plus loin que en tout cas
dans cette vidéo bref ce que je veux
dire c'est que le raisonnement de la
place ou de david dans cette vidéo
correspondre à des raisonnements
purement newtonien on l'a vu le trou
noir c'est pas vraiment une région de
l'espace est plus une région de l'espace
temps qui est infiniment loin dans le
futur
bref tout ça pour dire que les
intuitions newtonienne sur les trous
noirs ne sont pas valides en particulier
si les trous noirs sont noirs ce n'est
pas parce que la lumière ne peut pas
leur échapper
quand on regarde un trou noir ce que
l'on voit c'est en fait tous les objets
qui sont à la surface de ces trous noirs
et on a vu qu'il ya énormément de
matière à la surface d'un 3
puisque tout ce qui tombe sur le trou
noir reste figé à sa surface tout cas
pour nous qui sommes extérieur du
tournoi et du coup la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est plutôt pourquoi est
ce que ces objets qui sont figés à la
surface du trou noir ne sont pas
visibles et là l'explication c'est
encore une fois la dilatation du temps
qui crée un effet doppler ultra massif
de sorte qu'un objet qui est à l'horizon
des événements la surface du trou noir
aura une lumière qui est infiniment
décaler vers le rouge
une lumière qui est infiniment décaler
vers le rouge c'est une lumière qui est
invisible et donc pour faire référence à
ceux dont j'ai parlé dans l'épisode 22
sur la théorie du big bang
la raison pour laquelle les trous noirs
sont noir et en fait à peu près la même
que la raison pour laquelle le ciel est
noir c'est à cause du décalage vers le
rouge
idée fausse numéro 5
les trous noirs sont des objets ultra
dans ce rayon de fatigue d'un trou noir
est proportionnelle à sa masse du coup
le rapport m / le rayon de schwarz
schilling est une constante
or la densité d'un trou noir elle va
être proportionnelle à m / lorient de
ford field au cube et donc si on réécrit
cette expression on voit que la densité
peut être inversement proportionnelle au
carré du rayon de sortie du trou noir
ça veut dire que la densité des petits
trous noirs va être énorme
mais la densité des trous noirs
supermassifs peut-elle être assez faible
et en fait on estime que la densité de
sagittarius à étoiles ce trou noir
supermassif au centre de la voie lactée
est comparable à la densité de l'eau
alors je mets un petit bémol à ce que je
viens de dire
le rayon de fortes il est en fait pas
vraiment le rayon du trou noir
en fait c'est ce qu'on obtiendrait si on
observait un trou noir de très très loin
mesurez soit taillé angulaire par
rapport à laquelle on le voit et qu'on
multiplié cette triangulaire par la
distance qui nous sépare du trou noir ce
que je suis en train de décrire ici
salaire correspond à utiliser la
métrique dit de schwarz fils dont on n'a
parlé dans l'épisode hardcore mais comme
on l'a vu dans l'épisode hardcore
justement les distances près du trou
noir sont incroyablement déformés vous
pouvez imaginer qu'elles le seront
encore plus à l'intérieur du trou noir
bref tout ça pour dire que mes propos
sur la densité des trous noirs est à
prendre avec des pincettes mais il ya
beaucoup plus étranges
techniquement si on en croit vraiment
injuste les équations de la relativité
générale il pourrait exister des trous
noirs complètement vide
en effet l'équation de schwarz qui
décrit les trous noirs sans rotation est
une équation dans laquelle on n'a pas
besoin de masse pour l'écrire l'équation
est valide dans le vide complet en
particulier si on en croit l'équation de
schwarzschild on n'a pas besoin
d'énergie de matières pour déformer
l'espace temps pour le courbet l'espace
temps peut être naturellement courbet en
présence d'un trou noir qui lui est
complètement vide ta vie sûrement
uniquement d'une bizarrerie
mathématiques mais dans l'histoire de la
physique il ya eu pas mal de bizarreries
uniquement mathématiques qui ont fini
par être des inspirations profondes à
l'origine de nouvelles découvertes des
sciences l'art fin apparaît des
paradoxes temporels et bart toutatis
demande si l'âge de 13 milliards
d'années est un âge qui est absolu ou à
ce qui est plutôt relative du coup
est-ce que différents objets on subit
différentes histoires à travers l'espace
temps et du coup devra avoir des avis
différents
alors pour comprendre cet âge de 13
milliards d'années il faut bien se veut
rencontre qu'on a fait l'hypothèse selon
laquelle l'univers est homogène et
isotrope ce qui est assez vrai à grande
échelle et que du coup en première
approximation tous les points de
l'espace-temps ont à peu près la même
histoire à travers l'espace temps du
coup en première approximation
il y a un caractère assez absolue
finalement à cette halte 13 milliards
d'années cependant si on regarde un peu
les détails et on voit qu'il ya des
particules qui ont interagi les jeunes
avec les autres ou qui ont subi des
forces non gravitationnelle est donc d
accélération à travers l'espace tente
qu'elle conduit à des trajectoires pas
droites et du coup ces objets là on fait
des bonds vers l'avant en moins de temps
et du coup sont moins âgée aujourd'hui
que l'ex trajectoire qui ont été des
lignes droites que jusque là un autre
phénomène qui peut arriver c'est des
particules qui sont passés près des
trous noirs auxquels cazeau ont traversé
des régions très courbé de l'espace
temps et à ce moment là il ya encore une
audi natation du temps pour ces objets
là et du coup ces objets qui sont passés
près du trou noir sont aussi plus jeunes
que 13 milliards d'années aujourd'hui
donc 13 milliards d'années c'est une
espèce de borne supérieure tous les
objets de l'univers opus 13 milliards
d'années une la plupart d'entre eux ont
quasiment un peu près 13 milliards
d'années mais il peut y avoir des
particules aujourd'hui qu'ils ont moins
de 13 milliards d'années
j'ai sorti nos vidéos jeudi dernier sur
l'axé ration vers le haut du sol et ça a
fait réagir bon nombre d'entre vous et
ça m'a fait super plaisir de voir que
vous avez réfléchi à cette question et
même si vous n'êtes pas convaincus vous
y réfléchissez et j'ai l'impression que
y en a pas mal qui prennent plaisir à
rien c'est ça qu'ils veulent parce que
dire je veux revenir sur le commentaire
d'aurélien perdriau qui pose la question
qu'est ce qu'un référentiel exactement
c'est une question qui me semble très
difficile aussi très importante pour
éviter des erreurs lorsque l'on pense
l'activité générale et pour commencer je
vais vous dire ce que l'on dit en
mécanique classique en mécanique
newtonienne on représente souvent la
terre avec un référentiel en disant baba
ce référentiel à ces trois flèches à ses
trois coordonnées vont permettre de
repérer tout ce qui est dans l'espace
temps et on peut considérer d'autres
types de coordonner dont douteront trois
flèches comme ça on a des théorèmes qui
dit que deux référentiels inertielle
sont telles que les deux heureux repère
les deux flèches son mouvement
rectiligne uniforme l'impa poseront
particulier les angles entre les
différentes directions sont constants
travers le temps nous vraiment dans
cette image un référentiel c'est quoi
c'est vraiment trois repères qui évolue
dans le temps lorsque ni en chine c'est
que des référentiels que l'on croyait
inertial comme par exemple au
référentiel qui à la surface de la terre
en fait ne sont pas les bons référentiel
ne sont pas la référence à l' naturel
pour faire la physique se sont pas des
référentiels inertielle les bons
référentiels et référentiel universel du
référentiel en chute libre
or lorsqu'on prend une image de newton
on a l'impression que ces référentiels
en chute libre vont se rapprocher les
uns des autres est tombé en accélérant
et donc du coup ne vont pas être en
mouvement rectiligne uniforme du vin
pour une chaîne lui erreurs que l'on
fait lorsqu'on fait ce raisonnement
c'est qu'on a supposé que le référentiel
au centre de la terre était un
référentiel qui permet de référencer
tous les autres référentiels est
vraiment le message clé d'einstein c'est
de dire qu'en fait un référentiel
inertielle n'est valable que localement
ça ça veut dire que si on prend un point
qui est éloigné d'un référentiel
on ne peut pas utiliser ce référentiel
locales pour opérer le point qui a
éloigné les référentiels inertielle dont
une validité que dans un petit voisinage
de l'espace temps en particulier on ne
peut pas utiliser le référentiel
inertielle au centre de la terre pour
étudier des mouvements qui sont éloignés
qu'ils sont par exemple à la surface de
la terre
en fait ce que je suis en train de dire
cela correspond exactement à dire que
l'espace temps et courbes dire que les
référentiels sont black hole aux
calmants ça correspond même en termes de
géométrie différentielle à dire qu'on
étudie uniquement des référentiels qui
sont des espaces dont jean mais qui a
des connexions à fines de fer entre ses
différents espaces
bonjour j'utilise un petit peu les gros
mots mais ce que je veux vraiment dire
par là c'est qu'un référentiel n'est
vraiment valable que localement et il
est très difficile de raisonner
globalement avec ces référentiels fait
pour raisonner globalement on obligé
d'utiliser des espèces de cartes de
l'espace temps comme la carte de choix
s'il dont j'ai parlé dans l'épisode
hardcore et la difficulté qui va venir
avec l'utilisation de ses cartes de
l'espace temps c'est le fait que il faut
vraiment utiliser des repères différents
dans la carte et ça ça veut dire que les
trois flèches aux ailes seront
différentes à différents endroits de la
carte dans certains endroits certaines
pièces ou plus beau rendre que dans
d'autres endroits
lorsque l'on déplace ses trois flèches
d'un point à l'autre on a des trucs très
bizarre par exemple la manière dont les
flèches se déplacent dépendent du chemin
qu'ils ont choisi dans l'espace temps et
ceci ça va me permettre aussi de
répondre à la question de bécyk dave qui
demandent si le sol accélère constamment
vers le haut est ce qu'il finirait pas
par avoir une vitesse très très grande
c'est une question que j'ai vu à
plusieurs reprises dans vos commentaires
une question extrêmement difficile et la
raison pour laquelle finalement non le
seul à pas vraiment une vitesse
astronomique c'est qu'il faut toujours
la compare à quelque chose une vitesse
est toujours relative donc si on dit
qu'à l'invitation promis qu'il faut dire
par rapport à quad par rapport à
certains jurés oui elle va avoir une
vitesse astronomiques mais ce que l'on
sous entend le faire qu'on pose cette
question c'est pas pour un truc qui
serait sur terre et qui avait une
vitesse nulle part au sol
un moment donné sauf que si on prend un
avait un truc en chute libre qui et
lutèce nul à un instant donné et qu'on
me laisse aller
ou comme le seul accélère vers le haut
bâle le soldat pour une grande vitesse
par rapport à cet objet là et du coup
cet objet là va se retrouver très
éloigné du sol de la terre du coup le
seul va se retrouver très éloigné du
référentiel inertielle en chute libre
sont encore une fois on indique qu' à
cause de la courbure de l'espace temps
on ne peut pas étudier des mouvements
très éloigné de référentiels inertial à
l'opposante dans l'espace-temps courbe
c'est pour ça qu'en fait on peut pas
vraiment dire que le seul va prendre une
grande vitesse parce qu'en fait on peut
pas dire par rapport à quoi il va
prendre une grande vitesse par rapport à
des référentiels qui avait une vitesse
nul à un instant donné et qui sont des
référentiels inertielle ces référentiels
inertielle là vont aller tellement loin
qu'on va pas pouvoir les utiliser pour
mesurer la vitesse du sol de la terre l
inverse les référentiels qui sont
attachés au sol ils sont attachés au sol
du coup ils vont avoir la même vitesse
que le soi et du coup ils vont avoir une
vitesse nulle par rapport au sol mais
ces référentiels là qui sont attachés au
sol se sont pas des référentiels
inertielle bref je suis pas sûr de
clarifier beaucoup la relativité
générale en disant tout ça mais j'espère
que ça vous aide un petit peu à
comprendre quelles sont les limites de
la façon classique la façon newtonienne
de penser la relativité générale et
quelles sont les choses qu'il faut
abandonner si on veut comprendre dans le
tissu général et j'espère que vous avez
aimé cet épisode la prochaine fois ce
sera le 25e et dernier épisode de la
série sur la relativité générale et on
parlera de la conjecture de poincaré qui
a à voir avec la forme de l'univers ça
ça veut aussi dire qu'on va bientôt
commencer une nouvelle série de vidéos
est le thème de cette série je vous
propose de le voter on peut voir sa
nouvelle forme il ya trois propositions
que l'infini la théorie des jeux et les
nombres une certain qui on demandait si
je finirai par parler des deux autres
qui n'ont pas été élus par vous il
répond celle que je ne peux rien
promettre voté six mois pour la
prochaine série de vidéos et je ne peux
absolument rien promettre
au delà de six mois donc quand vous
votez dites vous que ce qui ne sera pas
élu risque de ne pas être abondé
la clôture des votes ce sera le 31
juillet au soir à minuit pensez à voter
d'ici là vous souhaitez vous pouvez me
faire des dons sur tipi mais du coup
faut que je vous dise que home est
absolument pas de garder le rythme de
vidéos insensé que j'ai eu du scrutin je
ne sortirais sans doute pas deux vidéos
par semaine à partir de la rentrée
prochaine série j'essaie réclament de
garder ce rythme au moins d'une vidéo
par semaine notamment du format régulier
et bon voir ce que ça va donner
absolument vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à le lac et les commentaires de
partager abonnés vaut la chaîne pour ne
pas manquer le futur épisode et j'espère
que vous verrez la prochaine fois pour
reprendre les mots du physicien john
miller l'étoile disparaît à la dure que
nos chiens duché shire l'inde ne laisse
que son sourire derrière lui laurie
tremblay consacre à vie pour ces
qu'aujourd'hui au coeur de pratiquement
toutes les galaxies de l'univers siège
un trou noir